[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con tras la
muerte del astro argentino del fútbol
diego armando maradona el pasado 25 de
noviembre hoy nos acompaña julio ferrer
escritor biógrafo de maradona de autor
del libro 'dios miradas sobre el mito
maradona señor ferrer gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 por supuesto lo tengo apresar
preguntando por el legado que deja
maradona el fútbol mundial y llama la
atención también para muchos que para
muchos jóvenes que seguramente no lo
vieron jugar era su ídolo maradona
con días como estas un gusto si todavía
no se puede salir de la conmoción que ha
generado que diego armando maradona ese
artista por excelencia del fútbol
mundial
acha se haya ido físicamente pero de
alguna manera ha quedado inmortalizado
no solamente en la tierra que lo quiera
hacer acá en argentina sino también en
distintas partes del mundo
maradona queda como el hombre por
excelencia el artista por excelencia del
fútbol mundial pero no solamente por sus
virtudes y su excelencia en el fútbol
sino también un hombre comprometido con
su tiempo con las cuestiones políticas y
sociales
por eso también maradona se lo va a
recordar como un hombre que nunca relegó
de renegó de su condición de clase y por
eso acompañó los distintos procesos en
américa latina y por eso su amor
incondicional hacia la cuba de fidel
venezuela de chávez maduro la bolivia de
evo entre otros hace que maradona va a
quedar inmortalizado como el hombre que
entregó la belleza en el campo de
deportes y el hombre que entregó también
su voz y su cuerpo a las causas más
justas ahora julio maradona también
vivió una vida de excesos una vida
pública muy controvertida además también
por lo que se te hablaba era si en
intimidad como era como era diego
mira yo pude conocerlos a diego y
después en las más de 80 entrevistas de
cargo en este libro 'dios mirada sobre
el mito maradona no solamente es
futbolista dirigentes políticos
periodistas no sólo destacan la belleza
inigualable del absurdo de maradona sino
destacan la calidez humana de diego y la
esencia de su espíritu el gran amigo de
los excesos con respecto a su vida
privada 1 yo no he analizado mucho esas
cuestiones porque todo lo que decía ese
gran pensador latinoamericano que era
eduardo galiano decía que diego es el
dios más humano que reúne sus
contradicciones sus virtudes así que yo
creo que la vida de diego que quedará
inmortalizada por las infinidades de
alegría que dio al mundo con el fútbol y
él llevó a lo máximo porque él tuvo ese
don en sus pies y creo que lo llevó de
la mejor manera posible julio le
pregunto si maradona en algún momento
habló sobre cómo quería que lo
recordaran luego
vos sabes que digo cuando hablaba con
respecto el día que llegará esa hora él
quería que la gente no lo olvidara que
la gente lo recuerde y obviamente que
uno lo que está viendo en distintas
partes del mundo el amor expresado hacia
la figura de diego quedará inmortalizado
pero a mí me cuesta entender que ya no
está porque uno veía los ojos de diego
últimamente y se veía un poco la
tristeza la soledad a uno le genera
dolor porque uno pensaba que la vida le
iba a dar una nueva oportunidad para que
él pudiera disfrutar un poco más de años
en la vida terrenal y la vida le era esa
oportunidad pero no pudo ser ahora julio
que hacía que maradona despertar a tanta
pasión entre las personas y sus
seguidores esa magia digamos en torno a
maradona
esas son las cuestiones que quizás lo
hacen esa magnitud del personaje ese
amor que despertaba ya sean los sectores
humildes en los sectores más pudientes
unían a los credos políticos
maradona generaba eso por eso será un
mito por eso era un dios que lo hacen
tanto creyentes agnósticos ateos hace
que por eso maradona es inexplicable
sale de cuestión de cualquier otra
lógica y por eso queda como el icono
planetario por excelencia julio gracias
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en esta entrevista en france 24
y ustedes televidentes también gracias
por siempre estar conectados ahí en
nuestra pantalla hace una próxima
oportunidad buen día
[Música]